[Music]
anybody who like [ __ ] got super rich
off of just scooping up every url yeah
and selling those oh those [ __ ]
yeah those guys are so lucky when they
park all the damn names i heard the ufc
had to buy like ufc.com back for like
two million or something yeah where
there's like a whole business that was
parking all right off of ufc.tv for a
long time i feel like a lot of them are
korean too
yeah i feel like a lot of korean people
just like bought a bunch of urls and
stuff and then they just like sell them
afterwards dinosaur.com no one has that
one dinosaur phone.com no one has that
that's smart as [ __ ] though you would
never know you do it to tubers too
because i had a guy who was parked on my
domain which was stevegreencomedy.com
because i didn't snap it up back in the
day when i started my [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] funny but [ __ ] up and then he
would dm me on instagram and he's like
hey man like let me know we can work
something out and i'm like bro i will i
am so petty i will literally never start
a website you just keep paying
you could just keep on paying yeah i'm
like you go ahead bill you squad on
there he squared on for like three years
and i just actually just snapped it up
hey let's go dude but isn't it cheap to
park like they could park it for like
six bucks a year or some [ __ ] yeah
but i think he faced the reality that i
was never ever to start a [ __ ]
website and now i'm just parked on it
just because i love investing in the
wrong person petty [ __ ] to be honest
petty stories are the best i don't even
know what i will go through
random uh or more back to the non-random
stuff you guys ever seen those [ __ ]
giant uh like
[ __ ] what do they call it agriculture
where they grow like giant [ __ ] fruit
or vegetables for guinness world records
there's like people that are like
they're professionals
like affair but like they literally
that's their job biggest pumpkin or
something yeah exactly
can you eat it so we're actually talking
about the genetically modified largest
pumpkin
in the u.s right get a personality okay
i saw a [ __ ] sign on the side of the
freeway the world's biggest [ __ ]
pumpkin i'm like you [ __ ] line stacks
of [ __ ] dude get the [ __ ] out of here
with the biggest anything bro get the
[ __ ] out of here i saw the sign what
about biggest titties dude get out of
here dude what world's biggest titties
out of here are you kidding me
you don't like those come on the biggest
is not always the best now we know he's
gay
[Laughter]
biggest is not always the greatest first
google says annie hawkins turner women's
breasts weighs 89 pounds each we talked
about this already did we talk about
this yeah and it was fun as [ __ ] her bra
size is 102 zzzz well that's crazy bro
victoria's secret
life with this poor woman dude those
teeth are so big
that they're asleep
her titties so big she needs to use
hammocks
dude her tits are so big she must like
be in pain all the time it must not be
fun to hang out maybe she's like a hipaa
she just stays in water and she's like
titty so big she got a hunchback there's
like buoyancy to it
dude she probably walked by here and
nick would be the first guy to [ __ ]
nut
first guys just nothing
she goes by dude god that's not hot at
all i'll go oh just to answer your
question the all-time record for a
pumpkin grown in the united states was
set in 2018 by steve geds of boscawen
new hampshire whose pumpkin tipped the
scales at 2
528 pounds show me this pumpkin sir well
well before that we're going to get into
today's rx today's article is about a
guy a wisconsin farmer who grew a
2520 pound pumpkin believed to be the
heaviest grown in the country this year
2020 about to win an award wow
and then it gets disqualified
due to a nail-sized crack on the
how the [ __ ] is this exterior
gonna move it you gotta keep it
perfectly like you can't have a crack it
weighs a ton
you cannot have a single crack uh in
order to to qualify for the competition
wow oh my god [ __ ] that that's a dub
rule big [ __ ] that's the biggest
[ __ ] pumpkin
it's a big [ __ ] pumpkin yeah but
what's the crack gotta do with it what's
a crack gotta do that the country was
fall weighing in at 2
520 pounds however it's not going in any
record books because it was disqualified
from competition james crowe explains
what went wrong i would [ __ ] uh this
is a giant pumpkin
weighs in at
2520 pounds
well this is the heaviest pumpkin in the
country it's not going down in the
record books that way it cracked no but
before we get into that meet the grower
my name's mike schmidt and i grow a
giant yeah right i want to see how small
is this crack like big it's a nail sized
craft i do think it should be
disqualified for not standing up yeah
there needs to be a round pumpkin yeah
you can't be laying out [ __ ] [ __ ]
plated like that be able to open it up
scoop all that [ __ ] out make a
jack-o'-lantern
why does it look like it was a it was an
old one like it would i could just die
that's just how they grow when maybe
when they get like superheroes
now now uh he's pretty much um it was
disqualified from the competition due to
a fingernail size crack in the
vegetables exterior and the grower said
that the crack is believed to be a
result of internal pressure from the
pumpkin's large size and the awkward way
it was growing so that does happen right
the default that fool should have
[ __ ] kept it
upright
dumbass you got an idiot dude this guy
doesn't have to grow pumpkins or if it
was a crack you just roll over to that
side and just hide it yeah i don't know
man it might explode or crack on the
other side that's like yeah how would
they see the cracks on the bottom he
said he's been growing giant pumpkins
for years but this year marked the first
virgin
he knows the chick with the biggest
titties for sure you know this guy's
going to be talking about it until like
he's like 90 years old like i had the
biggest pump this is definitely one of
those especially a fingernail sized
crack is what disqualifies the biggest
problem
grown in your life that's a dumb [ __ ]
rule see how long it took him to grow it
uh it doesn't but they do say that he
looks bright towards his future and he
says it happens there's no crying in
pumpkin growing that's what i don't like
about this though i wanted the video to
be him going like it was my dream yeah
yeah it looks like he didn't really care
no he didn't give a [ __ ] oh yeah so i'm
reading the wrong article he said [ __ ]
you guys
that's what i want to hear like a
[ __ ] angry athlete that's mad at a
call
yeah he wasn't that passionate yeah this
is like his side hobby where he's like
got a big lat like big yard i'm happy he
didn't win yeah i'd be passionate if i
was throwing the world's biggest pumpkin
just just to throw it in there why he
should be more pissed the pumpkin could
have earned schmidt a 22 680 prize from
the 2021 safeway world championship
pumpkin way off in california which
offers a nine dollar per pound prize to
the winner okay i see the value of this
okay i get it i'm back i'd be really
pissed i'm back on the board imagine a
fingernail is the reason why you size
crack on a
2200 pound pound murdering everybody
dude
i'm pissed do you grow that in one year
or it takes multiple i just feel like it
takes hell long and there has to be some
type of yeah like multiple something
he's pumping in there oh miracle girl
something like that
he's like i just use miracles right now
or dead pumpkins oh yeah fertilizer it
says 125 to 150 days to grow a giant
pumpkin really oh he just started yeah
dude
i don't feel bad creation time to be
anywhere from 125 to 150 days this is to
account for 60 days of plant growth and
80 days of fruit growth a little house
you think the inside seeds like that
each seed is this big or just a [ __ ] ton
of those that's true
probably the seed starts as big as your
head genuinely curious crack that [ __ ]
open and [ __ ] eat it i would assume
the seeds are big though yeah i don't
think it's like the same size like this
big i think it's this big but i would
assume the seeds are definitely bigger
than vinyl like the size of a vinyl
that's too big that's too big definitely
bigger that's big like a tennis ball so
if you plant that in the ground and then
water that with that pumpkin seeds
yeah right that's the jack in the
[ __ ] pumpkin stock i think we got
this pumpkin growing thing for i make
like a dozen pumpkin pies with that
yeah what does he do with that big ass
pumpkin that two-ton
look
here you go this will give you good
reference
oh pumpkin seeds are delicious man whoa
that's a pretty big pumpkin seed smaller
than i thought smaller than i thought
but that's still pretty big i'm sure i'm
sure that they can get bigger but so do
they use those seeds now to make another
pumpkin and then make a bigger pumpkin
and a bigger puppy yeah for sure
probably the [ __ ] breeding pumpkins
out there dude
pumpkin pie is
delicious all year i just realized what
i'll eat [ __ ]
pumpkin pie tasted like you never had it
before i've had the pumpkin pie and i
realized like oh this is pumpkin i had
no idea i thought it was like sweet
potato my whole life because i'm an
idiot
it's kind of similar
it's crazy we're in pumpkin pie season
like pumpkin spice i just discovered it
this year in fact this [ __ ] goes
to cairo's again tomorrow for some
pancakes and steak you know he should
bring some pumpkin pie for us yeah we're
gonna get some pumpkin pie
to deliver it let's do it what a nice
guy dude i was just at vallarta bud and
they got pumpkin spiced tamales right
now dude dude vallarta is the [ __ ] bro
that's a hybrid it's slept on where's my
yard
it's like it's like the mexican whole
food it's a grocery store yeah
like a value plus so good they have
strawberry [ __ ] tamales usually
but
yeah but this one's seasonal i was like
oh have you did you try it no i didn't
try i smelled it though
i love the smell of pumpkin you know
i'll smell all pumpkin stuff when was
this discovery for you dude like this
year dude at least you found it you're
not completely yeah yeah
i'm proud of you actually thanks man
have you had pumpkin bisque i like that
too i've had lobster biscuits lobster
bisque i like pumpkin soup it's [ __ ]
very good mom dude i love pumpkin man
bisque
it's just smash dude
is that peanut that's steve's [ __ ] uh
jack-o'-lantern yeah i would do that
it's a jack-off that's what he made with
the pumpkin i like how he has comb drips
too
i'll say detail
i would have loved to be in like a like
an elementary school and everybody has
to like do a jack lantern and you're
just so good that you can do one of
these there's a vein in the middle yeah
wow yeah this guy
is sick dude that's what i think it
looks like in my head when i'm doing it
and then it just looks like a really
shitty dick
when i actually look at it hey
everybody's dick drawings are a
reflection of their own penis is that
why mine's held small just
no you just need bigger parchment or
whatever you draw on a bigger pin yeah
bigger pen that'll do it or a pumpkin
seed that's bigger